what's happening reject nation
greg and john donald here today this is
actually friday we're shooting this
but you're getting this on saturday the
godzilla versus kong official
exclusive godzilla meets kong clip the
shake hands and then uh godzilla says
something racist
or in reverse oh yeah true and then kyle
chandler tosses the coin up in the bell
ring
intro complete sports jokes 30
seconds long let's do this
[Music]
what the heck
now the music
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
is
they're just dragging that [ __ ]
that roar here we go
it's worse than the please stand by them
cuts to black yo
was that them meeting that was them i
guess they were saying hi to each other
it was them coming face to face at least
making eye contact
oh that music it sounded like classic
godzilla music i mean yeah it's just
that big
brassy ominous just full tone you know
the villainous godzilla is back in full
form
unless you read the uh article where the
filmmakers revealed all the secrets you
guys can watch our video where we do
uh go through that article where chris
from 3c films was breaking it down
and i was like damn these filmmakers
they don't they don't give two shits
they're just gonna say whatever they
want
one part of me was wondering when it
came to godzilla in this movie
the fact of how he's you know going bad
maybe
he's successfully like destroying stuff
but not harming human beings
he's waiting until they've all backed
yeah he's like
destroying buildings yeah but no i mean
when he's attacking these naval ships he
is destroying you you could see him
if he slowly shot down there's someone
just swinging around with this shot look
at that
oh my god is he tethered or just
floating
oh oh she's just shot out of the water
oh my god
the one guy who didn't get out see
godzilla killed one guy yeah godzilla
one is about underwater wilhelm scream
but i love too how it's like so
accidental almost it's like yeah he
crashes his tail into the ship and then
just like a piece of it gets hooked onto
his plates and there it goes
yeah like it does feel like just a
gigantic
creature whose these ships have gotten
in the way of almost
oh man he is uh yeah godzilla's full bad
i'm still team godzilla all the way what
do you think about this clip
which team are you on i cannot wait for
this movie i'm
pumped i am pumped leave your thoughts
down below hit that like button
catch you guys soon